- So we're told Circle P is below,
this is Circle P right over here.
What is the arc measure
of arc BC in degrees?
So this is point B, this is point C,
let me pick a different
color so you can see the arc.
And since they only gave us two letters,
we really wanna find the minor arc,
so we want to find the
shorter arc between B and C.
So the major arc would
be the long way around,
and if they wanted to
specify the major arc
they would've had to give us three letters
to force us to go the long way around,
so if they said arc BAC or BDC,
that would go the long way around,
but since they just gave us just B and C
we assume it's going to be the minor arc,
so we wanna find that arc
measure right over there.
Now, the arc measure is going to be
the exact same measure in degrees
as the measure of the
angle, the central angle,
that intercepts that
arc, so it's going to be
the same thing as the measure
of this central angle,
which is 4k + 159 degrees.
So if we can figure out what
K is, we're gonna know what
this central angle measure
is, and then that's going
to be the same thing as this arc measure.
So how do we figure that out?
Well, what might jump out
at you is that this angle,
angle BPC that we care about,
is vertical to angle APD.
These are vertical angles,
and vertical angles
are going to have the same measure,
they are, they're going to be congruent.
So let's set these two
measures equal to each other.
So we know that 4k + 159
is going to be equal to 2k + 153,
so let's get all of our K
terms on the left-hand side,
and all of the non-K terms
on the right-hand side.
So let's subtract 2k from both sides,
so we can subtract 2k from both sides.
And let's subtract, well
let me just do that first,
I don't want to skip steps.
And so I got rid of the
K's on the right-hand side
so it's just gonna be left with the 153.
And on the left-hand side, 4k - 2k is 2k,
and I still have + 159.
Now let's get rid of this
159 on the left-hand side
so let's subtract it.
But if I do it on the left-hand side
I need to do it on the
right-hand side as well,
so subtract 159 from both sides.
And I'm left with 2k
is equal to 153 - 159 is negative 6,
so K is equal to, just
divide both sides by 2,
K is going to be equal to negative 3.
Now you might be tempted
to say oh, negative 3,
but we're not just trying to solve for K,
we're trying to figure
out this angle measure
which is going to be the
same as the arc measure
that we care about.
And that's just expressed in terms of K,
so it's 4 times K + 159, so
that's going to be 4 times
- 3 + 159
well what's that going
to be? 4 times -3 is -12.
Plus 159 is going to be 147.
So this angle right over here
has a measure of 147 degrees
and you can calculate, that's
the same thing as over here.
2 times -3 is -6, plus 153 is 147 degrees,
these two are the same,
and so 147 degrees.
This angle measures the same
as the measure of arc BC.
Let's do one more of these.
Circle P is below.
What is the arc measure of BC in degrees?
Now since once again they
only gave us two letters,
we can assume it is the minor arc.
So we care about BC,
we care about this right over here.
And so what is the measure of this arc
is going to be the same
thing as the measure
of the central angle
that intercepts that arc,
and that measure is going to
be the sum of these two angles
so it's going to be 4y + 6
+ 7y - 7.
4y + 7y, we can combine the
y terms, is going to be 11y.
And then 6 - 7 is going to be negative 1.
So it's going to be 11y - 1,
and how do we figure that out?
Or how do we figure out what Y is?
We need to figure out what Y is
in order to figure out what 11y - 1 is.
Well, we know, let me write this down.
So the angle that we care about is
11y - 1, 11y - 1.
We know that that angle,
plus this big angle
that I'm going to show in blue,
that if we add them together
that it's going to be 360 degrees,
'cause we would've gone all
the way around the circle.
So we know that 11y - 1 + 20y
- 11 is going to be equal to 360 degrees.
And so now we can just solve for Y.
What is, let me get some
new colors involved,
what is 11y + 20y?
Well that's going to be
31y, and then if I have
- 1 and -11
that's going to be negative,
let me do this in a different
color, so that's going to be,
- 1 and -11, that's -12,
and that's going to be
equal to 360 degrees, 360.
So let's see, we can add 12 to
both sides to get rid of that
- 12 right over there, and
that's going to leave us with 31y
31y is equal to 372
and so if we divide both sides by 31,
it looks like 12, yep,
it'll go exactly 12 times
so Y is equal to 12, which is equal to 12.
And remember, we weren't
trying to solve for Y,
we were trying to solve for 11y - 1,
so what is 11 times 12?
We know that Y is 12.
11 times 12 - 1, let's see.
11 times 12 is 121.
And then 121 - 1
is going to be, oh sorry no,
my multiplication tables are off,
it's been a long day.
11 times 12 is going to be 132,
132 - 1 is going to be 131,
and it's going to be in degrees.
So 131 degrees, that's
the measure of this angle
which is going to be the
measure of minor arc BC.